Zach Bruce attended the concert but he
left early he was at Manchester's
Victoria Station which was located right
next to the arena when the bomb exploded
he captured the scene on videos as
panicked crowds rushed into the station
zach joins us now from Manchester's that
good morning to you
hi good mornin did I set the scene for
us what were you doing what did you see
well I was at the concert she was
performing her last song but I left
halfway through it because I need to get
back to my hotel and I was in Victoria
Station which is just right next to
Manchester Arena I was walking down the
stairs and then this huge bang just went
off I didn't know what it was but then
all of a sudden everyone started to
wouldn't run away from the same people
were crying people weren't being sick
parents looking for the kids parents on
the floor on one if the kids are okay
just all created what did you think was
happening Zach when you saw the people
running in that explosion what did you
think that was well I thought it was
like part of the show like like a must
have I go out with a bang but it was too
loud for it to be the sore I knew then
that it would be something different
more serious tell us about the crowd at
the concert tomorrow but it was mainly
kids about that event let me ask you
about security there was there any
security when you went into the concert
well the funny thing the waiting was I
went to show them a ticket but when I
was gone there no one else can tumour
say about anything um they just I just
shortened my ticket and then they let me
in and I see em ghosts no other people
were there no one was searching bags or
nothing so in the beginning Zak you
didn't really realize how serious this
was
no I just cuz I just took the bit I had
that special
I took the video and then I just work
your hotel because I didn't think about
anything serious you know so it's been
serious yeah it's very serious yeah
Chris we thank you for joining us this
morning no problem thank you